[Music]
hi my name is Patrick Ling and I'm an
engineering manager on the healthcare
and life sciences team here at Google
cloud our mission is to organize the
world's healthcare information and to
make it accessible secure and useful to
improve the health and health care of
people in communities globally today
we're going to talk about our offering
in the medical imaging space first we'll
hear from Homer kawar who is the VP of
engineering at AI digital his company
built a innovative teleradiology
solution on top of Google cloud platform
afterwards we'll hear from my colleague
Sascha vesicular he'll be walking us
through the cloud architecture of the
system and then finally I'll be back up
here and I'll be talking about the
platform underpinning all of this which
is the cloud healthcare of API and with
that I'll hand it over to Omer thanks
Patrick hi everybody thanks for coming I
know it's the last day and people
probably have flights and things that
they want to get back to so I appreciate
the the people that did come we have a
lot of exciting things to talk about
today at I didn't is to essentially
deliver better patient outcomes through
the application of advanced technology
when our founders sat down they looked
at the entire healthcare sector and
determined that the the area of the
industry that was most ripe for this
kind of benefit was in fact radiology
and specifically teleradiology so they
thought about the problems that they're
trying to solve there over 35,000
radiologists less than 3 percent of them
are networked there's no common platform
and a decided lack of technical
technological advancement this market is
very large it's 5 billion dollars but
it's a highly fragmented mix of
solutions and so what we're running into
is essentially
two major areas of challenge in the
market itself
we've got radiologist burnout happening
now there's a couple of factors that are
feeding into this one is that
radiologists are being asked to read
more and more so the volumes are
increasing also radiologists are being
asked to do it faster oftentimes there
are patient expectations you know I'd
like my reading back fast
there are also clinical concerns if
there are emergent indications that
things need to be turned around rapidly
so whilst the volumes going up and
people are asked to do their work faster
the technology hasn't been able to keep
up in addition another trend that's
worrying is that coming out of medical
programs we're having fewer and fewer
people actually opted to do radiology so
there's all these factors are driving
radiologists individually to try to do a
lot lot more on the same platforms and
systems that they've been using for
decades we looked at some market surveys
and and found that satisfaction amongst
the users and users the radiologist is
down at the 40% level and for a 5
billion market to be down that low and
just to be clear that 40% satisfaction
is with any of the solutions that exist
it wasn't their particular solution so
they're essentially saying there's
nothing there that that really helps me
execute my work rapidly and achieve
those patient outcomes that we're
looking for and finally with the trend
in fewer and fewer radiologists and the
increasing cost of healthcare that
everybody's aware of we're finding that
we get very poor rural coverage and
institutionally also there are
challenges in delivering radiological
care on the technology side we've got a
lot of problems we've got cumbersome
data exchange so with any industry with
any technology that has been around for
few decades what we're finding is we've
got a lot of different systems they all
speak a little bit differently and so
we've got all of these point-to-point
integrations going on and that's in the
radiology workflow so from end to end
you know they could touch four or five
different systems provided by four or
five different vendors and as those
vendors have software that gets released
you know we've we essentially have
problems in those integrations that's
leading to low reliability so it is not
uncommon and you know people that are
not in the field may be shocked by this
but it's not uncommon for AD ologist to
essentially show up to work and not be
able to work their platform that allows
them to do teleradiology
just is not available for hours at a
time
and finally little innovation so I
mentioned that before with the legacy
systems that are in place and the
technology that exists what we're
finding is it's very hard to get some of
the cutting-edge technologies
specifically machine learning models and
artificial intelligence to be applied
people are working very hard some of you
are in the room on on these technologies
and they're running into real challenges
in delivering that into the workflow for
radiology I mean I was talking to one
vendor that has to actually I mean
they're a team of data scientists and
they have to take VMs and put them in
sites in order to deliver that you know
this this is really these these high
roadblocks are causing causing people
just not to use the technology and then
finally scalability so all of the things
I talked about from a fragmentation
perspective from a technology
perspective are leading to are leading
to an inability to scale any of the
individual solutions that are on the
market today
across the country so our solution so
what we looked at was to create a cloud
native zero footprint teleradiology
solution the entire solution
is built on the cloud including that
DICOM store so for those of you not in
the industry that's essentially the
images from the various modalities so
those are on the cloud which is believe
it or not a significant step there's an
embedded die computer so that also is in
the cloud and so you know that's
important to reduce the multiple vendor
approach that currently exists today and
then both risen packs capabilities are
built into the platform from a machine
learning and AI support perspective you
know the step one was to create a
platform and then start to drive in the
capability to add machine learning and
AI from from cloud solutions that exists
today
embedded voice support is an important
important work enabler for radiologists
and then streamlined integration with
facilities so those of you that don't
work in the space may not understand how
difficult it is to actually connect to
facilities whether that's a hospital or
an urgent care center in some rural area
but after we went live as VP of
engineering those are all my problems
and so it was great to get some of the
experience on our team
you know decades of experience doing
this at the beginning so that we could
build into our solution capabilities
that actually make that faster you know
it see it seems seems like the the
simplest thing to do but it's actually
being the hardest to achieve and in
practice so now I'll talk about the
platform itself so those capabilities
can be broken down into technical
building blocks later on we'll go
through this in detail so I'm not going
to spend too much time on this slide
going through every bullet but I do
think it's important to kind of have
some context for the capabilities that
are there data ingest so as I said many
many many points this is all HIPAA data
so it contains patient information the
images themselves need to be secured so
we needed to make sure it was both
secure and scalable and scalable
to thousands of points and so you'll see
that in in our solution today later on
the platform itself so this essentially
is the work management it's the
workhorse of the the platform and that's
doing all of the management of the work
that's coming in assigning that out to
radiologists managing access all of
those things that you would expect from
a work manager this is also where we
would introduce clinical AI based
decision making the image viewer it's
already on the cloud our images are on
the cloud we have very low latency in
image fetch which again is a challenge
based on what I've described today and
messaging so again we'll talk about this
in detail why we went this route but it
was important to have the scalability
within the system to pass information
back and forth and mobile so I I think I
referred to earlier kind of a lack of
access from an institutional perspective
so we made a mobile tool set that allows
essentially mobile radiology to be
enabled essentially these are
technicians that drive around with a
mobile unit and they can visit
institutions such as jails or hospitals
elder care centers and our platform
enables that workflow also seamlessly
and finally machine learning so you know
that that's really the the I think the
point of making a new platform is to
enable that and we'll talk in detail
about how we did that and and what the
capabilities are to to essentially
create that continuous loop of learning
and then underneath this all a data
store so it was important that the data
be very close to the application the
latency that that users experience today
is very much related to where the data
is where are the images where's the
patient data and so it was very
important to bring that close and on the
same platform so why do we pick Google
for this solution well as you can see on
the left side all cloud services provide
you know a set of capabilities and so
what distinguished google for us was
really that they had created and were in
alpha with a HIPAA compliant data store
and that was the crux of the decision
they're also the seamless scalability
that we get with kubernetes multi-region
networking and then the rapid ml tools
that some of you have seen today and
additions to those that were announced
at the conference so so what does that
mean from an engineering perspective
well it meant that I could work with our
design teams our smees in the space and
essentially use these tools sets and
accelerate the delivery of the platform
itself I don't need to sit there and
redesign everything from scratch my
engineers don't need to go in and make
all of these things I can leverage the
services and capabilities that Google
has and later on we'll talk about
specifically which ones so what did we
learn working with Google
well we found them to be a very active
partner as we went and designed our
solution there was a very much a
conversation with them about the
approach we would take how we would
solve various problems we ran into and I
can't speak enough about the healthcare
team you know they were awesome
throughout the process in addition we
worked with zazz make our engineering
partner and they were critical to in in
getting to market fast so again some of
the cloud services I mentioned that
accelerated our time to market and we'll
go through those in detail so technical
lessons learned going through this
process of making this platform from
scratch cloud native there were a couple
things we learned that are pertinent in
healthcare so number one resource
matching was a key activity so what what
do I mean by that essentially as we
found these pieces of data coming from
various sources getting that data
associated with both the
and the order that was going on was
critical and to be able to do that at
scale so we're talking petabytes of
information that needs to needs to hook
together and be related at the point
that the radiology is trying to perform
their tasks association of DICOM based
studies with orders has many edge cases
so those of you that have tried to use
this standard will understand the
standard is not standard and every
vendor has interpreted it their way and
then finally scaling we needed to scale
we needed to scale fast and we needed to
scale without affecting our production
clients so we solved this in the first
case with micro services and pub/sub and
in the second case by introducing and
accommodating the flexibility that
exists in DICOM and on the third with
gke and we're looking at sto and service
mesh there was announcement at the
conference on service mesh also that
we're very interested in so we'll
continue to work with Google and with
our engineering partners to to achieve
those so next Sasha is going to come up
and talk about the architecture in
detail Thank You Omar
appreciate everybody being here I'm very
grateful to be on this stage and talking
to you all about this very interesting
solution a little bit about myself
before joining Google I was director of
medical informatics at Columbia
University for many many many years many
more years than I'd like to admit and
it's from that background and learning
that I have an appreciation for many of
these technical challenges that
organizations are trying to solve large
and small ultimately to drive better
patient outcomes so what we're going to
do today is talk through the specific
architecture that we put in place for
with I digital to help facilitate this
zero on Prem footprint entirely
cloud-based solution I'll just highlight
a couple of the steps right now some of
the key things that I think everybody
should be focused on networking so
networking is critically important of
course as soon as you start talking
about moving to the cloud how are you
going to facilitate that so the network
connectivity is absolutely critical
from that we move deeper into the stack
we talk about how Google cloud platform
organizes its internal structures around
the concept of a project mllp and DICOM
those are two critical legacy protocols
that are ubiquitous in the healthcare
space and any organization looking to
move into this kind of method of working
in the cloud needs to understand the
limitations of email both mllp and DICOM
and how you can overcome those
limitations and we'll talk about that in
a little bit more detail from there I
want to point out obviously the
healthcare API the healthcare API is
really pivotal and central to the entire
conversation of the architecture what it
allows you to do the kind of
capabilities it provides the kind of
systems and services you can build
around it and then ultimately the
healthcare API
go into even further detail with with
Patrick when he speaks in the third act
you know Omar picked up on something
very quickly which was I like to think
of it as liberating data so right now to
facilitate day-to-day transactional
operations between providers and
patients those data systems are siloed
they're isolated within the on-prem
environment as we move into the future
the question becomes how do we leverage
that data to provide better service
again ultimately driving better patient
outcomes
servicing more patients and really
meeting the challenges that all
organizations are facing today in
healthcare so by bringing the data to
the cloud you get to take advantage of
all kinds of functionality that's
present in the cloud in particular we'll
talk about bigquery underpinning the
whole exercise of course is security how
do you ensure that you are in compliance
with very stringent HIPPA regulation
regime
so obviously HIPAA is is the law of the
land in the United States of course we
are you know we have global presence so
we'll talk about HIPAA today but this
same conversation plays internationally
all kinds of jurisdictions are
introducing data protection related
regulation in general and also in health
care so as an organization that's
looking to take advantage of these
products and functionalities you
obviously need to make sure that you're
doing it in a very secure and regulated
fashion so let's talk about the network
connectivity what are we trying to do
here ultimately we're looking to bring
data from where it's being generated
into the cloud and in order to do that
you have to have good network
connectivity if you think about
teleradiology the way that those
providers access this information
is that they have to get that
information from where it's stored and
traditionally that information is stored
on premises where it's been generated so
think about all of the networking
activity issues that a specific physical
facility may have now let's turn it
around though think about what the
networking opportunities and
capabilities are of Google so we have a
major major of networking presence
globally with tremendous options up and
down the stack specifically dedicated to
networking particularly in this solution
we're looking at our cloud VPN solution
and this is what really enables you to
do a fully zero footprint installation
ultimately the key thing that the
physical facility needs to enable is the
VPN termination if they can enable that
VPN termination in their networking
stack connected to its endpoint in the
cloud that's basically all you have to
do yes there are other solutions you can
look at various interconnect solutions
for higher degrees of bandwidth you can
look at even point-to-point secure
tunnel those are a little bit higher up
the stack you go from zero footprint to
maybe 99 percent no footprint so cloud
VPN was really our our first intent and
our first interest to facilitate this
technology the the key consideration
here is that the VPN will route the
traffic to the appropriate IP address
not just externally but also internally
as we continue the conversation we look
at kubernetes etc we'll see how those
all those IP considerations come into
play project
so I spent a little bit of time earlier
talking about this in Google cloud
platform the kind of one of the major
areas of abstraction in the system is
what we call the project and if for any
of you who have worked with Google cloud
platform platform previously you'll be
familiar with this concept the project
is where you put all the things so all
of your networking resources all of your
virtual machines your kubernetes
clusters etc etc they all exist inside
of projects in why should we consider
projects as a major boundary for the
architecture of the application data
isolation obviously as as a technical
provider technical services provider I
digital is looking to onboard many many
customers we want to ensure that their
data is completely isolated from any of
the other customers in the system
specifically the the hard data the DICOM
images themselves also the project is
where billing happens so when you create
a project you create an Associated
billing account and all of the resources
and consumption of those resources
within that project are then charged
into that billing account so for an
organization that's looking to onboard
many many customers you want to have a
very very close accounting of what those
underlying resources are costing so this
by isolating at the project level you're
able to have a very very fine-grained
control or insight into what all of the
resources are costing on a customer by
customer basis again due to the fact
that the project is the kind of base
level of abstraction all of the things
that are in the project healthcare API
Google Cloud buckets of Google Cloud
Storage buckets virtual machines
allocation of reserved external IP
addresses etc etc all of those items
have quotas associated with them so
quote
management is hat is handled on a
project-by-project basis so again this
is how you are able to isolate various
customers from clobbering other
customers etc etc and they maintain
their entire individual ecosystem and
then finally security projects again not
just data isolation but access to
projects are controlled via I am GCP I
am which is identity and access
management and you can have very very
fine-grained control over which systems
which people which accounts which
services can access all of the things
within the project so for this
particular implementation use case
without digital we have many projects at
play here we have production development
demo where I digital is able to spin up
a completely de-identified system and
demo it to prospective customers etc
what you'll see is and we'll talk about
it in particular logging again cloud
audit logging stack drive these are all
very important pieces of the overall
conversation and what we in health care
and life sciences group within Google
Cloud recommend as a HIPAA best practice
all of the projects all of the
independent projects in the system can
outbound their logs to a audit and
logging dedicated project that can be
staffed specifically by compliance
compliance organization separate group
of people no bleed anything like that a
project per customer talked about that a
little bit and finally all of these
pieces can be automated and this is this
is one of the pieces of the word scale
how do you scale this solution to
accommodate you know hopefully you're
going to do a good business you want to
accommodate lots and lots of customers
how do you as an organization
enable the onboarding of all of these
customers and managing of all of these
scenarios it has to be automated so
everything we're going to talk about
today can be automated through cloud
deployment manager g-cloud cube control
kubernetes kubernetes is kind of the
base layer of scaleable abstraction from
a computational perspective and this
particular use case calls for using
kubernetes to scale both the MLP and
DICOM adapters and the application
specific services the key part here is
that is the networking so the kubernetes
cluster itself controls the ingress
networking from your external on-prem
customers to their specific MLP and
DICOM adapters of course everything in
the kubernetes cluster is connected to
the entire logging infrastructure and
what kubernetes really brings to the
tables as I said the ability to scale
the computation but on watch on which ty
mentioned do you scale how do you
determine when you should scale there's
new developments of course always coming
new developments so GK enables you to
scale on custom metrics so for example
MLP is lightweight from a data
perspective it's high message volume
DICOM is a little bit heavier because
it's the actual image so they have
different scaling dimensions and by
integrating with custom metrics for
scaling they can scale independently MLP
and DICOM adapters this is really a lot
of the meat of the architecture Google
publishes open source MLP and document
actors and the way that you should think
about them is as a bridge on
one side they receive legacy MLP and
icon protocol communication on the other
side they egress healthcare API protocol
so this is the real workhorse here this
is what enables you to bridge the legacy
on-prem environment the ubiquitous
presence of these protocols in virtually
all hospital oriented systems around the
world
- your cloud-based solution and again as
I mentioned these services are exposed
via private internal load balancer IP
addresses those addresses in turn are
routed through the VPN we W know the
kubernetes cluster basically plays
double duty in addition to the hosting
the MLP and document actors we're also
hosting services so the classic service
oriented architecture micro services
pulling together a specific set of
business logic to accommodate a
particular business task into a specific
process and these processes do various
things for example in in this use case
we're creating orders so as messages
come into the system they they emit
notifications into cloud pub/sub we'll
talk more about that in particular and
these services listen for those
notifications and when they get those
notifications they do specific things so
for example they might listen for a
DICOM message and then create the
Associated or M hl7 message they might
listen for the RM angel 7 message and
then create an order in the
transactional cloud sequel database in
the I digital application itself
resource matching Omar was mentioned
that briefly how do you match an hl7
message
- its DICOM study how do you do all
these things so and then finally billing
we highlight billing as well of course
major component of the system you want
to think about how those bills they need
to be delivered to those organizations
healthcare API all kinds of interesting
things happening here that Patrick will
talk about in specific detail but some
of the things that I wanted to highlight
in particular for this use case and
implementation are the data store
architecture design so we we have
highlighted here in the application in
the in the architecture three different
data stores one for our M's and our use
so that's requests for reports and then
the report reply dfts detailed financial
transaction or in detailed financial
transaction hl7 messages and then of
course DICOM messages so or mor you are
in one data store dfts are in another
data store die coms are in their own
data store and we had an interesting
design this design decision to determine
well do we need one for real-time and do
we need one for priors or for those not
in the in the business the archive of
all of the previous images that were
done and due to how different micro
services we've architected various micro
services in the system we decided to put
them all together in one DICOM store
each of those data stores then output
into their own cloud pub/sub topic and
these topics of course are critical this
is where the micro services listen for
various pieces of information put in new
pieces of information and there are many
ways to interact with these pub/sub
stores the takeaway for these is that
it's completely integrated so this is
completely managed by Google cloud
platform there's all kinds of
capabilities to interact with the queues
to act or acknowledge messages from the
queue or not acknowledge messages from
the queue ensuring that they get picked
up
at a later date configurable retention
the messages stay around until they're
processed etc etc bigquery this is
really interesting part of the
conversation and I spoke a little bit
about it at the intro omer mentioned it
going to the cloud shouldn't be an
apples to apples conversation it should
be an apples to fruit basket basket
conversation you get all the things
because going to the cloud unlocks all
of the other opportunities in the cloud
in particular here we're highlighting
bigquery so bigquery is Google's data
warehouse system and once you get data
into bigquery you can do all kinds of
interesting things you can enable
analytics you can enable more advanced
analytics we love to call machine
learning sprink a little bit of machine
learning on everything and everything's
better right but you got to get the data
there first it has to get there the way
that we've designed the healthcare API
is that it easily can export data into
bigquery and cannot underestimate easy
easy is incredibly important
big queries got all the goodies it's
scalable it's fully managed auditable
again integrates with external reporting
tools like looker and our data studio
tableau accessible via standard ansi
sequel so for those of you in the
audience who have a sequel background
this is fantastic
a unity viewer the unity viewer is the
DICOM viewer itself so this is a
commercially available product from from
another company we integrated it
integrates directly with the healthcare
API it's specifically designed to have
various pieces of functionality
segmented so we have a front-end web
application we have a data cache proxy
we also have a computational engine that
just executes 3d volumetrics and the key
takeaway here is that because it's
delineated you can execute
civic fine-grained access controls the I
digital application itself runs it's in
its own project and it has many
different components running in virtual
machines using cloud sequel storing all
its data in the transactional database
has its own access control for front end
users and ultimately again is separated
from the services that access various
parts of the system so this is security
isolation and reducing that footprint
that might cause challenges from a
security perspective talked a lot about
the logging separate project for logging
specifically an opportunity to segment
all logs and make them only available to
your compliance organization again HIPAA
best practice isolation ability to
transfer these logs into bigquery
similar to the clinical data do all
kinds of advanced analytics anomaly
detection
do we have problems or the wrong people
accessing this data etc etc finally
because this system is so flexible you
have the opportunity to send your data
to various billing providers and the
billing providers of course like
everybody else don't really share
standards so you need to be able to
speak to the specific billing provider
that your customer has a contract with
and what are their capabilities native
ap is being able to send specific
billing D of T's the batching CSVs this
again ties into the service micro
service architecture being able to
create the right materialization of your
billing log and get that sent to the
provide to the billing provider in the
way that they can consume it and again
it's the the system here is delineated
within its own micro service
architecture so with that just a quick
recap
this was a really very fast walkthrough
of a complete end-to-end architecture
with zero on-prem footprint completely
in the cloud everything is operating the
cloud using many different GCP function
a pieces of functionality everything is
automated everything I talked about here
can be automated and we're working
continuously to do that to create the
automation scripts with I digital cloud
deployment manager G cloud cube control
finally we leverage many different
components of the cloud so it's not just
healthcare API you got to bring all the
other pieces together networking
security bigquery and ultimately the
healthcare API itself is storing this
very critical healthcare data and with
that I want to pass the baton to my
colleague Patrick who will tell us more
about the healthcare API Thank You Sasha
so so what is the healthcare pie we've
heard a lot about it in Sasha's
architecture so fundamentally the way we
think of it is it's a managed scalable
and secure platform for your healthcare
data so we built the health KPI to be
interoperable so it that means it can
talk to your existing systems in the
healthcare space and it also supports
industry standards that we encounter in
the healthcare space we've designed it
to be developer friendly and easy to use
for our customers of course security and
compliance are very important concerns
in the healthcare area so we built the
health KPI with robust security and
compliance features in mind
finally the health KPI is designed to
allow customers to really unlock the
value of the data that they saw in it
for example this is done by integrating
with powerful analytics and machine
learning solutions so as we heard
earlier in the talk most customers in
the healthcare space today have data
stored in a variety of different
on-premise systems typically those are
fairly fragmented or siloed so you'll
have separate data systems for different
types of data different systems may be
for different geographical locations you
might have different systems in
different parts of a healthcare
organization and it's very difficult for
data to kind of like travel from one of
those systems to another
so what we've done with the health KPI
is we are aiming to allow our customers
to bring all their data together in a
single place the way we've done that is
by integrating with existing system so
this includes packs and VNA system so
those are systems that customers use to
manage their imaging data today and also
integrating with EHR systems which have
structured healthcare records we heard a
little bit about this earlier we support
natively a number of kind of the most
common formats that we encounter in the
healthcare area so on the imaging side
this is primarily DICOM so DICOM is a
format for storing medical images and
also the metadata pertaining to those
images on the electronic health records
side we support fire an hl7 we heard a
little bit about the adapters also so
these are some open source components
that we've put out there to make it
easier to interact with what we think of
as the legacy protocols of exchanging
those types of data notably DICOM timsy
as well as mllp so what do we mean when
we say the health K API is developer
friendly well like most GCP api's it's a
modern restful api built on top of HTTP
and gr pcs so the goal for us really was
to allow customers and developers to
focus on their business logic while
Google would worry about things like
backups configuring VMs and setting up
databases the health KPI is a fully
serverless API so so that means all
scaling and serving infrastructure is
all handled by Google's infrastructure
we integrated the health KPI with Google
Cloud console so this provides our
customers with a graphical user
interface for easily managing the
resources stored in the API cloud
pub/sub I think we heard about it in
Sasha's
diagrams this is just a very powerful
versatile mechanism for plugging any
kind of like custom processing logic
into your healthcare workflow so we
think of it as almost the Swiss Army
knife of integrating with our API
healthcare data is probably one of the
most sensitive types of data out there
and I'm sure most of you will know that
the privacy is heavily regulated in the
healthcare space
so that's why we designed the health KPI
from the ground up with a very robust
set of security and compliance features
built right in like all of Google Cloud
the health KPI is built on top of
Google's trusted infrastructure so it
benefits from the same multi-layered
security we have built in fine-grained
access control so this allows customers
to use cloud I am and specify exactly
who gets access to what parts of their
data and then they can also go to cloud
audit logging where they can verify
who's actually looking at what and maybe
detect any anomalies that that might
have occurred HIPAA compliance is table
stakes when handling health care data
with personal information in it so we
built the health KPI to be to support
HIPAA compliance and we regularly sign
BAA agreements with our customers in the
space which is a which is a legal
requirement we have also built the
health KPI to support data locality so
what this means is a customer can
specify where in the world they want
their data to be stored this is
important for health care customers in
many jurisdictions where there are data
residency requirements that they have to
comply with one of the key benefits of
using the cloud health KPI is that it
allows customers to bring all the health
care data from where it resides today
and assemble it in a single place where
they can reason about it holistically
and finally we also have some mechanisms
in the cloud health KPI that allows
customers to then take those models and
actually deploy them into a clinical
workflow so for the remainder of the
talk I'd like to walk you through three
key scenarios or three key use cases
that we've encountered when working in
this space so first of all I'd like to
describe how we can support research and
clinical viewing of medical images using
the cloud healthcare pie next I'll talk
a little bit about high performance
analytics using bigquery and finally
I'll get into machine learning and how
to train and deploy models there so the
health KPI is a is a flexible platform
for viewing medical imaging data images
can be ingested into the healthcare pie
either from a PAC system directly so
this is kind of sim
to what we saw in in some of the
architecture diagrams previously so
where we have images traveling from from
a non-parent pack system into the health
ka P I may be using one of our adapters
but we also support bulk import from
Google Cloud storage and the nice thing
about the bulk import piece is that it
actually enables customers to use things
like the transfer appliance so this is a
tool that allows customers to do bulk
loads of very large amounts of data that
would maybe take a very long time to
send over the network with the transfer
appliance we can bypass that and get it
into the health K API more quickly we
have then worked with a number of
partners to build healthcare API support
into medical medical imaging viewers so
we already heard about one of them
unity there's another commercial view or
IMS that's also supporting the cloud
healthcare a P I but we've also worked
with a number of open source projects so
we asked this and ohef are a couple of
open source viewers that that also can
talk to the health KPI directly so for
all of these they can fetch the images
directly from the API so it's a truly
serverless end-to-end viewing experience
on the analytics side of the story we
rely heavily on bigquery so bigquery is
Google's
petabytes scale high performance
analytics engine it's something we built
originally for our own internal use at
Google to understand user behavior on
some of our consumer facing products so
via the cloud health KPI we're making
this powerful tool available to our
customers in the healthcare space by
allowing customers to load their
healthcare data into bigquery once their
data is in bigquery becomes very easy to
join across different data modalities
join in additional datasets maybe join
in some public datasets we have some of
those available like the rxnorm data set
which is a prescription drug database so
you can maybe come by and your
healthcare records data your imaging
metadata and maybe some genomics data
and then you can sort of really start to
reason about those so there is a nearly
endless lists of use cases for this so
I'm kind of highlighting three of them
here so we've got some customers that
are using bigquery to identify and
select cohorts to include in research
studies so select a list of patients for
instance and then maybe materialize
their data de-identified and hand it
over to researchers we've also seen
customers using bigquery for clinical
decision support so this is
an example where maybe we want to find
similar patients to the one that a
provider is currently looking at and
finally because bigquery is fast it
allows fast turnaround on queries so
it's it's a very useful tool for
iterating on things like quality and
performance metrics where we want to
start measuring things in the healthcare
enterprise that very hard to do in the
existing on-prem silos finally let's
talk a little bit about machine learning
so one of the key benefits of the cloud
health KPI is that it can bring your
health care data to advanced machine
learning solutions so these machine
learning solutions again can take
advantage of the full spectrum of
healthcare data it can healthcare
records imaging data genomics data you
name it we integrate with some powerful
labeling tools so those can be used by
customers to curate high quality
training datasets for their machine
learning use cases and then we can make
those data and labels available to cloud
machine learning engine and auto ml
which are some of the advanced machine
learning tools built into cloud built
into Google cloud platform so cloud
machine learning engine you can think of
it as our hosted version of tensorflow
so this is something that allows
serverless training of machine learning
models Auto ml is a tool that sort of
specialized for customers that may not
have a lot of data science the machine
learning expertise at their disposal and
and it's a powerful tool that it can
allow customers to train models even in
those contexts finally once the
customers trained a model the health KPI
can also help them deploy thus model
back into their workflow so for example
if I have a model that can help me
understand an x-ray image I can use the
cloud health KPI to bring the prediction
from that model back into the existing
pack sphere so radiologists can view the
model prediction alongside the images
when they're doing their read so one
thing I would like to announce is that
the cloud health Kay API as of last week
is actually available in public beta so
that this means it's something that's
now available to all Google cloud
customers to use we also have some
public datasets but some public imaging
data sets available hosted on the cloud
healthcare API already so this can be a
great place for you to start playing
with some of our viewer integrations and
maybe start trying out some of the some
of the tools that we discussed today so
notably hi
the NIH chest x-ray data set on there
and we also have the cancer imaging
archive on there alright so with that
I'd like to thank you all for your
attention
[Music]